Alo Alo ạ
anh alo alo chào bạn
Ừ Ok chào bạn à
32 phút nào ạ
có 2 phút để mà tranh thủ tâm sự
Mình xin phép Tâm sự cái ý chuyện thì ra
mấy hôm nay khá Hà Nội
em đổi về về cộng đồng mạng
thứ gà mình không tính của mình thường
là không quan tâm mấy cái về chống biến
zama vân Nhưng mà nó nó cũng mình thấy
nó cũng khá là ảnh hưởng được cậu là vì
mình cũng đã mình từng là nạn nhân của
việc là bị bắt nạt Học Đường
cho cô bé thì đúng rồi Mình cũng từng là
đứa đi bắt nạt đúng không Tôi không cho
rằng ở tôi bị từng đi bắt nạt người khác
đâu mà chẳng qua tôi từng đánh nhau
nhiều thôi nhau Tôi hiểu rằng là chính
xác nó trêu tôi tôi đấm nó ấy còn chứ
không có kiểu dạng là tôi chủ động đi
Đài ngay cả con cái khái niệm bất nạt
thì theo như tôi hiểu Nó là kiểu dặm mà
không chủ động ông đi kiểu ca khiển
người khác rồi ông bắt nạt kẻ yếu hơn 2
Vân khi mà người ta kiểu không thoải mái
nhưng vẫn cố tình làm điều đấy thì nó sẽ
vẫn là nó là đây không có mỗi về mỗi bạo
lực mà có thể là bắt nạt về tinh thần là
nhiều nó sẽ làm ảnh hưởng đến nỗi là
mình không muốn đi học lại chẳng hạn là
tôi thấy khả quan ngại về cái vụ gần đây
nè tôi mới lên tiếng
đã lên tiếng ở đây Dạ không hẳn lên
tiếng thì ở cả tôi Chuyện chia sẻ một
cái bài thôi nhưng mà tôi cũng muốn nói
một tí một góc nhìn của tôi về cái vụ
việc gần đây tôi không nói à Chả các bạn
cũng đang biết là tôi đang nói về cái vụ
việc nào về cái vụ mà tôi thường ra tội
không rõ lắm đâu lúc đầu có chụp tết
kiểu cách nào đang mấy cái vụ đấy Tôi
không muốn đọc rồi à
Ừ nhưng mà nhưng mà cuối cùng thì tôi
cũng vẫn phải được bởi vì đọc một cái nó
là ý kiến trái chiều
khi đọc xong rồi tôi mới bắt đầu đọc
thêm rồi mà đặc biệt là cái vụ mà khiến
nó tôi đọc đó là là kiểu dạng mà nhiều
người hùa theo để mà đánh giá đánh giá
sao để mà
anh nhắm mua sao như đánh giá nhầm sang
đại học đấy Nếu không biết bộ để không ạ
Tôi thấy cậu ạ Cái việc hồi như thế
không phải tốt mẹ nào
Ừ thì tôi đang nói à tôi vẫn không nói
được ạ đang ai đúng ai sai nhưng cái
việc hành vi mà hành vi mà kiểu mình hùa
theo để làm một cái gì đó tẩy chay một
cái gì đó Nó nó có thể được cho là tinh
thần dân tộc của mình cao nhưng mà nếu
mà làm sai thì nó lại bóp không ạ đó lại
cả khiến cho cậu bị đã thấy con bị ra là
khi mà thông tin từ một bên đăng lên các
bạn cứ hùa theo để mở gì Mở ra đã cũng
không xem không thực sự là đội đội không
được sự đội Anh ở cái thông tin xác thực
các thứ thứ các bạn cứ vào chuyển với ra
đã Các bạn cứ kiểu tố cáo cho Vân đã
nóng lại sau đó thì thậm chí đó à
khi tôi thấy à
cho tôi tôi vẫn không nổi
cho tôi vẫn không ra nói là trường hợp
đúng sai ở đây nhé Ừ Thì lúc đầu thì tôi
chia sẻ và tôi Cậu nghĩ rằng mà là tôi
không đồng tình nhiệm việc là tôi cũng
xem cái đoạn clip về việc là ông nhà
giàu kia ông ấy tỏ ra khinh khinh người
khác kiểu dạng giờ đúng kiểu đấy bố mày
ai không theo đúng giờ hết đấy thì tôi
không thích kiểu đấy
Ừ nếu mà không có lửa sao có khói không
ạ vẫn nghĩ trường hợp đấy Tôi không nghĩ
là chỉ tự nhiên một chiều như thế
Ừ thì à
kể từ khi mà tôi thấy có một bài được
đăng lên bởi vì PH ở dạng là góc nhìn
theo hướng khác thì một loạt bình luận
vào hùa theo kiểu
áo kiểu rảnh tao xuống mềm đọc chúng ta
biết chắc rằng nó mày tờ trắng rồi Thế
là tội không thích kiểu đấy tao không
thèm đọc nghĩa làm thì đúng xác định Hả
Cái gì một chiều tao chỉ muốn một chiều
thôi mà cái tư duy ở đây đó là đúng là
cái người nào loài chim trước người nào
đăng truyền thông lấy lấy được gọi là
lấy được à Kiểu lấy được lòng truyền
thông trước thì người ấy có vẻ có cửa
Thắng đã cả người đấy còn được cái là
truyền thông ủng hộ điểm là
người ấy mượn cái mát là tao nhà nghèo
thằng kia Nhà Giàu nó Cậy có quyền thế
nên là kiểu dân mình bất bình nhanh hơn
dân mình chắc là phải dùng dân mình rồi
đấy ạ nước ngoài thì ở nó nó chắc là nó
sẽ khác mình có thể làm để chỗ khác nó
không cũng không mùa thu khác của mình
thì hơi nhìn thấy dân Mình rất thích cậu
bảo vệ người yếu thì đúng mình mình có
người yêu mình thấy ai đó có phải là
thấp cổ bé họng hơn thì mình sẽ rất đồng
cảm rất muốn bảo vệ người đấy để hiệu
ứng truyền thông Tôi thấy thật ra về các
bạn thì nó có cái tốt à khiến cho
gọi chính quyền Tân Hiệp và đúng ạ để
xem xét kỹ Nhưng mà đấy là thì tốt ở
điểm nào mình lên làm một cái gọi là một
mức độ đấy thôi còn việc mà tôi thấy
Star thôi rồi không thèm nghe bên khác
nó gì các thứ thứ cho thể thở ra
đây đáng sợ lắm Tôi cũng thứ đáng sợ đấy
do mà nhờ Nhiều lúc tôi bảo vệ mấy ông
đó là tôi muốn mình là người có tầm ảnh
hưởng tất nhiên là có Đó là kiểu muốn
giúp đỡ người khác muốn kiểu mình người
có tiếng nói với Vân
Ừ nhưng mà khi mà mình đã lên rồi cái
mực ngưỡng mà mình có thể bảo là nhiều
người biết đến các cử thứ thì mình lại
rất sợ mình rất sợ là kiểu Chính những
người đấy về sau chỉ cần có một cái xử
gì đó hiểu nhầm thôi Mình chưa kịp đính
chính vì chưa kịp làn đăng một cái gì cả
tự nhiên một người đang một chiều với
tôi em ạ tự nhiên rất nhiều người hùa
theo thuốc gì rồi cũng chết luôn biết
được à cái cái bây giờ cái cộng đồng là
đáng sợ đây nếu biết được rồi ông ạ
có gì à
vì nó có thể đang bất kìa tin gì kiểu
kiểu nó chẳng cần gửi chứng cứ gì cả
đang đấy rồi một loạt người ấy hồi theo
cái gì ngoại
anh Bởi vì dân mình thì đa số thì có sắc
kiểu có sao Google lại để xác nhận đâu
Tôi phải dùng từ đấy đúng mấy ông đọc
mấy ông có giờ tra Google sao xác thực
lại cái tin không hay mấy ông cứ kiểu có
tin trước đã anh đúng không ạ
anh nói chung là tôi tôi thấy cái đáng
sợ là đấy do Thứ nhất là tôi không muốn
hả nó cực kỳ nổi lắm cái cái sau lại
phải cẩn thận những cái toàn bộ những
phát ngôn của mình là thứ hai là mấy ông
thấy là tôi thường ra sống rất là sao
Tôi không sợ cái gì cả Tôi muốn sống
thẳng như thế để không phải sợ gì cả mấy
ông Khi mà khi mà ông sống thẳng ông
sống thật với mình ý nghĩa là nghĩ gì
nói nấy giống như ngay tôi bây giờ chẳng
hại
anh nói khéo nhiều lúc nào nó bị lươn ý
đang cả là nó ra tạ Ông thích cả tạo cái
thứ nhất thứ hai đó là là nếu mà ông ông
không ngay thẳng ông không ông không
sống với cái Tâm ấy thì về sau kiểu gì
nếu mà ông nổi lên Tý kiểu dìm sẽ
chị
sẽ dính vào một cái gì đó mà người ta
kiểu gì có thể gì mong Bằng chính cái
đấy Cái này là tôi nghĩ là tốt nhất là
mình cư theo dạng giống như tôi ngay giờ
này mấy ông có Phố Tội chẳng biết bóc
phốt tôi cái gì nữa
Ừ
thì tôi tôi nghĩa là có tôi vẫn đang
hưởng đi đúng mà tôi cũng không muốn về
sau cực kì nổi cứ tầm tầm như thế này tự
nhiên là về sau chắc chắn là sẽ phải gọi
là cành bằng tiến lên mà đang tiến lên
thì kiểu gì cũng sẽ có thêm người biết
nhưng mà đi rồi không hẳn về sau một
Cookie nổi
Ừ cái tầm kiểu một lần 2 sinh tuần chúc
bạn ơi Rồi với sau hơn trăm thước ý đến
nhìn thì nó một con số rồi đáng sợ dùng
thứ đáng sợ
xin phép là đầu tiên mình trả lời mình
có chia sẻ thêm một vài cái tiện ích mà
mình sẽ thử ví dụ luôn cho mẹ các bạn
nha có tiện ích này tiện tiện ích để mà
Cho hỏi tên nó nói đến tất cả nó cho
phép copy và đơn giản chỉ Bôi đen ở với
cha nào đó mà nó cấm không cho đây là
trong trường hợp mà trang này nó dùng
thẻ ra là nó rung mà nó vẫn là thể văn
bản cho thừa thứ còn nếu mà có nhiều
trang chưa tròn là nó chụp lại ảnh để nó
đẩy lên thì chị nhé chịu nha hoặc có
trang đỡ thì nó sẽ đè lên mà một ít khác
đúng như thằng là Instagram Instagram
Tôi không biết tôi giờ mở cái Instagram
của tôi lên đưa có bị nhạy cảm không tôi
cho mấy ông sẽ thử
cả
Bây giờ sửa ảnh như thế này nếu không
thấy là chuột phải vào không phải không
không hiểu lưu lại ảnh được vì sao với
bản chất là nó có người đít để chèn lên
trên cái đít này trên cái email đấy
nhưng mà rồi thì không xem inspec thì
ông sẽ thấy
có đít chèn lên như thế này thì ông sẽ
sẽ khó mà Đây đây mấy mình cười của ông
này nhưng có một ít vào xe lên đây này
thấy ông xóa cái đít này này
thì ông mới có thể lấy ra được ảnh Nếu
gửi cho ông ấy còn nếu mà không Nếu mà
có đít chạy lên như thế thì đúng là dùng
tiện ích này nó cũng không có tác dụng
lắm nhưng mà thằng này thì nó không chơi
được Kiểu chèn thêm cái đít như thế và
nó chỉ chơi đơn giản là nó nói chung là
nó không cho cậu sao chép cho thứ thứ
được nhờ Không sao mình cài hơn cần ích
như thế này thì yêu mình thể Bôi đen để
Coffee ngay được đấy
ở đây là tôi đang cài tiện ích rồi nhé
Còn nếu mà tôi mà không bỏ tích lại đi
thì ông sẽ thấy kiểu không thể Bôi đen
được ngày tôi đang giữ chuột không Bôi
đen được
dễ ngày thì thích để hợp cho việc này
ông đi copy cái thứ thứ
a tiếp theo chị đã có một cái ích nữa
cái rễ cây phù hợp với việc làm
người như anh Mạnh Tuấn ở hạ người chắc
là mấy ông làm việc đôi khi là mấy ông
mở một đống tác hoặc à hoa có giống như
điện tôi chẳng hạn cũng vẫn là tôi sắp
dậy rồi tôi sẽ phải mở một vài cái tát
thôi tôi cần lên đúng không ạ Chị
group.top này rất có lỗi ông sẽ
vì tình yêu tôi cài rồi
có tiện ích này thì ông sẽ tạo những cái
ví dụ rồi Bấm vào bấm vào thì nó sẽ ở
cửa mở ra toàn bộ với danh sách những
cái ông ông thể lưu tạm ở trong này nó
gần giống như kiểu bút mát đấy Cái ông
đọc tiếp Chẳng ạ đại khá như thế Và thậm
chí là ông kiểu cứ đến lúc học là ông sẽ
được tự động bắn mở thêm thế này mở một
loa Tab ra như này để đọc hãy cửa thế
ngồi đây là tôi toàn làm như thế này nhá
rồi đấy mấy ông thấy có tem lớn vừa rồi
không cứ mở máy lên tôi sẽ mở cái này
lên để đọc hết toàn bộ những cái bài mới
xong rồi đọc xong hết rồi tắt đi không ạ
Cái giúp 8 này rất là ngon là như thế
ừ ừ
a tiếp theo ở đây Cái này ra để về sau
tôi dậy về cách hoặc à hoặc là hôm nay
nếu mà dậy xong tất cả kia mà vẫn còn
thời gian thì tôi xin phép sẽ nói qua
một tí cách rất là hay cho mấy ông ngày
tham khảo còn gì nhỉ
khi tân sinh 80 thế
Ok Bây giờ thì mình à mình sang Út lên
nhỉ
Em hãy nhớ nói chuyện thôi chứ em chào
anh cái Min Ah
Ừ
thì hôm nay mình sẽ làm à Không hôm
trước làm thêm thì ra là thêm còn chưa
xong cơ yêu hôm nay chắc à làm nốt cái
thêm Xong hồi xưa
anh xóa được rất là nhanh xóa một nút ấn
xóa
của mình không ạ hành trang của mình à
Mẹ mua rồi này
Ừ tôi vẫn chưa là mau cho tôi bị quên
đấy mà cũng khá là bận là khá bận thật
Đừng kể chuyện là
em bận nói chuyện tình cảm có dính lưới
tình cảm hai thằng bận à
mới học mà học buổi này là tội phạm ma
túy
là nên vào cái khóa cơ bản của mình để
học
tổ chức khóa này đúng là khóa nâng cao
đúng rồi tôi phải dựng nâng cao nhờ tôi
hết cái chỗ thì đi rồi tiêu đề của tôi
đang bị say quá ơi
à à
ý là thêm 7 đăng hôm trước làm với chị
đến dừng đến đây thôi
hôm trước mình làm Dừng đến đây thôi Ừ
tôi xin phép tôi phải mở lại cái link
hôm trước vẽ cái vẽ cả giao diện cho
quyền sử Trang đấy đâu
do photo 2 online
Dù mai đây đây đây trang này
diện lúc trước đó ông ạ này
rất là nhanh thôi mình sẽ nhập cho nhập
các thứ minmax gỡ Cái này à Nhìn mắt
cũng thể mình mình mình Hình như là họ
xin lỗi đấy đỡ thì đợi tí nhé
ừ ừ
a Mimax mình có là optional nghỉ rồi
mình nghĩa là mình mình sẽ ưu tiên những
cái mà bắt buộc phải điền lên trước
những người chẳng con gái nào nữa thì
phải ngồi chẳng có ngày nào nữa đấy thì
à
Khi mà mình sẽ có dấu sao ở bên cạnh để
mình hiểu là những cái nào mà mình kiểu
dạng là mình bắt buộc phải điền
language
a language
năm cuối thì chắc à Phải có phải có thì
tôi sẽ là sao đây
Em nói đi này
Ừ nó sao hiểu là bắt buộc điên không ạ
những cái khác không cần điện được
a tiếp theo
à Tôi nghĩ là đáng lẽ mình phải chỉnh
cho cái hay cái này nó ở ngang cấp với
nhau ạ ngang cấp với nhau thì ổn hơn
lại sửa xe mà xe mà ở đít
group or group ngày nó kiểu cạnh nhau
rồi Gì nhỉ
từ ngày cãi nhau à xem nhé
đang nằm ở nhà được
không được không được ờ
anh em ơi tổng hai là cạnh nhau gì nhỉ
chat
nhớ bình thường làm như thế này Fami
like này nó tất cả cùng chung một dòng
thôi không muốn điều này muốn kiểu dạng
nhà nó có cái cạnh nhau có cái hiểu sẽ
xuống dòng
thì sẽ làm nhà nghỉ hay mình B rồi xuống
dòng à à
hợp này
Không đi
à à
Ừ chị thoảng ở tôi tôi Thực ra tôi không
chuyên nấu diện mày không thấy đấy Cứ
mỗi lần giao diện là tôi tốn khá nhiều
thời gian vào
A2 có phải cùng chúng nó
fluor giúp được
ở chung với ông nhỉ
quýt nó vượt ra ngoài thấy bổ vừa nãy
tôi vừa bị dính sau mấy ông tra về
cái khái niệm để mà nó xuống dòng ấy thì
ông cha là ố word
i grabbed như này cho CS nữa thì chưa
ở
đâu ạ thì mày ông sẽ cậu nó sẽ tự động
Xuống dòng cho không Khi mà bị dài quá
anh ở đây nó sẽ có hai cái một cái là cô
như này
kok hiểu rồi nó sẽ lập mặc định là tách
làm 2
em
gái tôi không biết chạy lắm
anh ở đây hay phom riêng không thể nhìn
xuống mày cãi nhau như thằng bên này một
con hai bên một con thế không không
không giải quyết vấn đề đấy Ở đây
anh xuống dòng xuống dòng
ừ ừ
phong rồi hơn à
em làm dâu
ok ok Cái này cháu phải xịn hơn này
À
hôm gốc ở đây đóng cái phòng lúc này con
ruốc không Rồi Ok Ok Ok
thì mình sẽ có một cái đít
a-class
cái lần đầu tiên dùng Ford đấy đâu mà
biết đấy
em biết Ảo thử xa a
ừ ừ
à À phải có thêm cái đoạn này nữa đúng
không
anh nghèo đồ nó phải thế này nữa không
nó bị bé quá mình sẽ mặc định là mình sẽ
cho cháu đi nữa
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ bắt chước thế mà nhảy
sang bên A A
em nhảy sang bên kiểu Min xe Dream exces
và quần xi nó ba hàng thì mình sẽ chưa
làm
a12 chia ba cái một cái 40 ạ
ở tuổi cô dâu nhưng mày Cái này chắc là
tôi tính được sẽ là mansory à
ở đây là
ông dễ thay là
ở nhà misuri
để xuất ra chị nghệ sĩ thêm nha à
à À quên class nhà
à à
nối nó bị lag xe máy ở chữ ra 10 a
mansory này
I make sorry
à Tôi đang nghĩ là tôi có thể ghi được
Kiểu ngay lúc thử xem nhé á
à à
ở đó Ok bị xuống dòng
Ừ vợ ấn mua cái phim tắt anh em an rồi
tắt
ấn đợi thì thôi mà lại
ở đây
có vẻ hơi nặng rồi đấy mấy bữa rồi bị đô
kiểu gì thì tắc sự đi
cài thêm cái tiện ích để mà Ơ ai để mà
Đọc cốt toàn bộ cốt của ông trong cái vô
trách này để vợ ý cốt trông nó có vẻ là
nó có vẻ là kiểu nghe về rất là ngon đấy
nhưng mỗi tội nó sẽ ngủ và rất là nặng
nó sẽ máy khiến mấy ông bị chậm người
không hiểu
nè Tôi gửi lại link rồi cho mày không
vào lãi rồi
cái bạn này tôi đang muốn là mình sẽ có
cô là sáu nghĩa là Sáu ở tháng 6 này nữa
cậu 3A
em biết được không để tôi muốn nói cho
nhỏ nhỏ giữa
U22 phải cãi nhau nghỉ sớm nhé
th2 Tôi đang muốn nói like cạnh nhau mà
hình như do dầu à rau nấu chưa này Thế
nó không cãi nhau rồi
em giả sử Xóa này đi đúng không Sao lại
đi này em không biết cãi nhau
Anh hello Nó bị nó xuống dòng nhỉ
ở phòng control ở đây
cái cái I like the class I like là gì
nhỉ
là WeChat
à à
Ừ chắc bà thôi
bộ phim ma
Hôm nay không phải 07
hai iPhone 7 ạ
tay của mày đi
A potent lên đi
mã số thuế
nào hay cầm xuống dòng
tôi biết tôi đang làm gì luôn nghe thử
à à
Ừ tôi muốn cách nó ra rồi nhỉ Ừ chắc là
kiểu như này nó sẽ bị à Hai thằng nó
cạnh nhau Nó sẽ
xe đẩy nhau xuống dòng Ừ thì mình sẽ xóa
là mày đi thứ thử thưởng thức xóa người
đi xem à
with là trăm phần trăm
ừ ừ
nhau nhỉ
tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh
chị xem nha xem mình đi giải quyết kiểu
gì cho hai hoài cãi nhau được
này cả
Ừ nó
ạ sau đó mình có mức phóng giúp nữa
khi đóng lại như này khi bạn xóa thay
địa tại sao lại ạ
bình thường xong hay là cãi nhau nhỉ
Ô thế mình tệ thật
em cảm nhận xe tồi tệ chúng ta cũng
thông cảm
I look for luminize Group
anh làm việc cái code rồi Anh dùng cái
Tab này
gì
sao không chờ tôi chứ không không giỏi
về CS lắm rồi chưa động hợp lách thôi
Tôi Đành phải chấp nhận làm nông dân Hôm
đấy ông ạ
Hà Nội Tôi có gì mà không sợ lại sau nhé
nhưng mà lên đây là để cạnh nhau mày
không hiểu ý tưởng đâu nhưng có vẻ không
được rồi tôi lại làm chuyện nông dân vậy
có chuyện ngay để mắt này
số đề mắt
từ nay ở được
Ừ
thôi cũng được cũng được cũng được
10 lỗi nhưng mà Thì tôi ở cậu hai cái nó
cạnh nhau nhìn nó tượng minh một cái
nhìn Cái ô này ông nhập nó dài quá Nếu
uống hình chung không cũng được không
sao không sao
vì
cuộc sống mà
vợ chồng trẻ nhỏ
sẽ là bản chất là mình sẽ cho chọn là
quần xi ngoại cho chọn Côsi và người
không không cho người dùng điện cố định
chỉ có một vài câu rồi thôi mình sẽ phun
Chi a a police Ê ở đây nếu uống ạ Sẽ
thưởng nha không ngắm nó thì alo nhé Rồi
đi
e-hero áo mới còn thêm vào đông à đồng à
a cool shoes upon
Ê bà
Em viết tắt là gì nhỉ
nó viết như thế nào nhỉ
à à
mình mình sẽ đưa nhiên mình phải đổ dữ
liệu vào trong này thẳng luôn rồi sẽ ra
bên cạnh trả lời tôi đổi
ừ ừ
phải trả về kiểu gì nó nay mình sẽ có là
canxi đúng ạ cool suy ngày bằng full
thế này
ở những sẽ có trả về data là canxi là cô
sinh ai ở bên này mình sẽ cậu sẽ ekip
Truyền thôi selex
à à
thì mình nên em là
là canxi sari ngoại
quần xi
à à
bài
hát của j
à à
thế này mà mình sẽ gọi iPhone X X
anh
hỏi
[âm nhạc]
mình sẽ có một cái options
à à
thì
mình sẽ trả về chả ra
Ừ không thì ở đây tôi sẽ có ở đây miếu
mỉ kĩ nhá Cái này là cái ba lô này cái
này tại cái key này thì bạn sẽ là tôi sẽ
có
Ừ cái cái này bên trái con cái phải đúng
không Thì được cái bên khá là quần xi ở
đúng không
À mà cái bên phải sẽ vào lu là giá trị
thật là mình sẽ in ra cái quần xi
ở này còn baru thực tế của nó sẽ là
thế này à
Tại sao lỗi này admin coci coci
Đúng rồi nhỉ
có một amin
bên Glass với bất nhầm sang đất ở
sẽ Reboot lại cốt hạn chế làm điều này
vì thực ra mấy ông được ăn Jones được
nhưng mà chúng cái này một cái tiện mà
Mấy ông ấy So sánh ngang này và có thể
vứt lại được cốt
Ừ nó
Ơ hay
em
đổi tại hai cái hôm nay mình sẽ có flash
ngoài
ở phòng control này đóng thẻ e
anh nó xin cho trí não
Ừ nếu ở thử ta thường là tôi sẽ tuân
theo quy tắc ở tôi sẽ cho tất cả toàn bộ
selects là C22 Tôi thích kiểu thế bởi vì
mấy ông cho chọn ở đây như thế này nó tự
nhiên nhìn thấy ai trong kiểu chọn bình
thường em với ông thấy nó hơi bị lệch
Em nói rõ
thế hả Có hàng nữa ở Hà nó nghỉ không
muốn cho thêm Hàn
à à
anh nữa đúng không còn nước gì nữa không
nhỉ
Canada cho là tôi thực ra là nâng nhật
thì mới ở tầng liên hệ em về tôi thôi em
ơi chú Quốc mấy à
à Tân có một công ty Trung Liên hệ đấy à
vì đồng tiền chung là gì quen sử ở nhỉ
trai nice dream II
vì nó có insee Phét vừa nãy mình tra
Cuồng Si ở này Bây giờ là gợi ý phát nữa
luôn à
à à
c ng cái này cái đi
a r mbl nhân dân tệ ra à code code của à
cái này là viết tắt đúng không thì tắt
ok
cha
mẹ mình có khá nhiều đồng loại tiền các
thứ thư như ngôn ngữ mình em ngôn ngữ
chỉ có tiếng anh vĩnh biệt thôi ông ạ
này
Ừ Ok có vẻ ổn Đấy
A và cái này sẽ thứ tự là đúng như là
cái mình lưu lại trong i5 Nhưng giả sử
mấy ông muốn ưu tiên đồng tiền nào thì
không thể đẩy thằng này lên trên như này
có bao nhiêu nó sẽ lên không ạ Mình lưu
lại thì vẫn là 12 Nhưng mà bản chất là
mình sẽ có thể đẩy lên kiểu ngày để lên
như này thì nó sẽ tự động đẩy lên thôi
ngoan ạ
Ừ Ok sang bên
em tắt bật máy này đi Sang bên này đi
qua mình qua mình mình sẽ
ở trận đi qua mình là mình
chị sẽ trong cái đít rõ là to
a-class là
phần nhút thôi Sau đó thì mình lại có
lây bồ có thứ thứ à à
à à
em
viết đúng chính tả không
Ừ tôi không biết này về sửa rồi
ở
đâu không biết
cách area ở không xuống dòng Dạo này
ăn cà ri cua Minh
à à
Xin chào anh bận đúng rồi
Ừ cái này form phòng control nó hình nữa
Nó không to ra không cậu cực kỳ to đâu
mình sẽ phải tự chỉnh nó nó mình sẽ phải
thêm ạ
thường mình sẽ chỉnh ko cho nó như này
bằng
ở Thượng 20 ạ
hẹn người to quá không to lắm nhỉ Ừ Ừ
nhưng mà như là tạm như này thôi nhỉ
này hơn đấy Con này đúng nhỉ cho nhớ xem
phone nhé
Anh nhớ là tôi dùng cái phone a tôi đã
cấu hình riêng phô này
này vậy sao bởi nó có cái khi mà nó
không có cái nem nhỉ
Ừ đúng ở đâu rồi
biết ngay mà
à à phun iPhone nó bị chỉ rồi đợi thì
ông tục số này không Em bây giờ mày cô
nào nhỉ à
ở Mỹ chỉ rồi hôn tôi à
cho iPhone 2G
chưa cài lại phone Tôi dùng cái
Anh dùng cái PR máy ông chỉ cần để ý kĩ
là cái cái dấu bằng mà nó sẽ nói thẳng
với cái dấu này là chuẩn cái phone mà
tôi tôi hồi trước dùng bàn thận chứa
tiếng Việt của nó trên đấy nó ổn nữa con
số này nó hơi xấu hôn này tôi thấy vấn
đề đó phun đây thôi đấy tôi dùng cái gì
nhỉ
hôn nữa thì không sao
Ừ nhưng mà Hồi trước tao không dùng cái
này tôi nhớ là tôi cài cái phone riêng
tôi phải tải cái phone này về cơ tôi cài
vào máy chứ không phải là thôn kiểu nha
thôi chúng ta cũng vậy được
hai
iPhone này không biết tiếng Việt có được
không Hãy xem thử tiếng Việt nha
Công Tằng Tôn Nữ Phạm Nguyễn Thị Diệu
Lan Em yêu thấy cái phone này tệ không
Tôi nhớ Tôi cảm của cái phun riêng để mà
nó không tại nhà
Ừ để đỡ hơn tí đấy đỡ hơn một tí thôi
nhưng mà làm mất cái Không không cậu
dạng kiểu như kia được rồi à
thế thôi nhớ nó là mua nô Lisa phải vậy
phone mua nồi Lisa
ở đây tôi cài full này
đi đái Chuẩn ông kia nói luôn này Follow
this a a
đấy đã
anh đã chia sẻ cái phone này rồi Nếu xe
máy
máy này chưa thôi nhưng mà
à à
nhóm đấy rồi chắc là tôi sẽ xem lại sau
người phụ này đẹp cực
Ô Môi Xa nhóm thị xem thử
ờ ờ
monalisa nha
Công Tằng Tôn Nữ Phạm Nguyễn Thị
Diệu làm đó nếu thế chữ chữ không hề bị
không Mày bị cái gì đó đúng không
Ừ đúng rồi tôi tôi không nhỉ Thật bởi vì
à Ở nhà tôi không Cốt nhiều thôi nên
công ty rồi mà cốt ở nhà tôi không có
nhiều nên hãy nha tội không để ý mấy mấy
cái kích thước kiểu lắm Thôi bây giờ tạm
dùng cái cái này cái này rất là đẹp mỗi
tội là tiếng Việt nó sẽ bị kiểu Nga
nhưng mà Tạm thời thì mình nó không đi
tiếng Việt mà nên mình không sao còn là
tôi sẽ cài cái mono đi xa phía sau
Cảm ơn em nha Thôi không đi nữa
Ừ
thì ông xã cậu nha chắc đẹp hơn một tí
trải nghiệm nâng cao trải nghiệm người
dùng
nâng cao trải nghiệm của người cốt người
dùng thì kệ người dùng còn gì không nhỉ
ta tết and này a number of piquant
ừ ừ sao để xuống dưới rồi
thì mình sẽ là xe Ford ra ở đây
đó trong này có phòng giúp nữa
nhanh hơn à Tôi đang cảm thấy mà thôi
tút lại lại đời
em Gợi ý đây gọi ý này sai rồi
Ồ vậy à
em hết á
tra Pháp
a guide mình hỗ trợ để mà xem like ở đây
được cả kiến nặng tiền tôi khuyên mày
không cần
tại sao thằng này nó lại cãi nhau nhỉ ào
ấy nhỉ tĩnh mình tí nha Có gì đó sẽ xảy
ở đây à
a a đã làm xong cái Deep rau thằng à Vãi
chưởng
Có đi đâu Ở đây Nó chưa đóng đi đâu mà
sao
à à
tô mới vừa bảo đây đó là mấy ông sẽ phải
thỉnh thoảng mày không phải kiểm tra lại
giao diện mình đang chung nha không phải
cố từ đầu đến cuối bay lắm tôi
biết tôi không
anh gọi không trên áo diện nên tôi càng
phải kiểm tra lại kỹ Bây giờ đây
đương nhiên là tôi thường ngay cho là
minmax thường mà về sau mình sẽ phải làm
thêm Mimax mình kiểm tra nữa nhưng mà
chắc là để cho bác em kiểm tra đi con em
mình kệ
đ.tp Hồ và Snap nó phải cô ấy đúng không
ạ
AE nhập hay thù Alo con nằm bờ anh đi
cân nữa
à Tôi nghĩ nằm Perfect convert sử cái
bên cái qua này cho nó kiểu
Anh đang bé ngon
em đỡ phải gõ ở xin rồi và đây mình sẽ
có một cái là
Thái Tô
Ừ cái snack mặn mắc này cốt là mình sẽ
hiển thị ra nhưng mà không cho người
dùng mà tiền nó sẽ ra kiểu à piton Đi
dạo ngay để cho người dùng xem thôi
10 người dụng điên lội lỗi Tôi nhầm nhầm
nhầm Dũng điện cho mày ý là nó sẽ Tí nó
sẽ tự động tự động Translator mà người
dùng vẫn phải sửa ngon mày giống thì sửa
tôi đã này tất cả cái này nữa hai thu
nữa
khi
mở tự động Điền cho người dùng vẫn thì
sửa lại
ừ ừ
Bây giờ tôi sẽ theo lôgic của tôi làm
như thế này nhá đó là tôi sẽ hiểu tôi
chọn Company các thứ thứ language các
thứ thứ xong rồi city các thử thử rồi nó
sẽ tự động Jura ra
ở trong này hộ tôi mỗi khi mấy cái thằng
này nó thay đổi họ sẽ theo lôgic rửa
ngay mình sẽ bắt sự kiện mỗi khi thằng
này một trong mấy cái này thay đổi thì
mình sẽ lại lấy lại ông ạ Mình sẽ bắt sự
kiện ở đây mình sẽ tạo một cái fan sân
là
cho tôi sẽ đặt tên nó là Channels các
bạn ở tên phát triển sẽ nên là động từ
lần đầu đấy đến nhà nên để tiếng Anh
càng tốt hãy cùng ai đấy nghĩa tự đào
tạo thay thủ ô
ở đấy và và mình sẽ lấy cái mình sẽ lời
language đầu tiên mình sẽ lấy ở đây mình
sẽ lấy đang quýt
các em ạ Mình có cái á select language
này à
Có ai có thể đặt tên là input cũng được
nha số đề cho mày cũng được không sao
đâu
thế language mình sẽ lấy Zalo của nó
A và
khi sinh ra sữa con Custom language ở
đây là Quyết ở đây có thể sử nhiều cho
như thế này tiếp theo là mình sẽ có City
II
ừ ừ
thể chọn nhiều đúng không ạ Con City chỉ
Chọn một thôi Còn gì nhỉ à
khi kompany language
xe open in comedy gì Á được thì sẽ lấy
là không quân đi
a stock company
à à
rồi thì mình cần à
ở thời sự mình sẽ
này này
à à
Ông Bà mình sẽ
Không những thế Điên hàng ở trong đến
nay
em thật sự ở Tôi muốn tôi muốn nó sẽ
theo cấu trúc kiểu Ngày Đó là kiểu Hà
Nội xong rồi à pp
Salah Swift
là nhờ hạn trong một tên của chị Company
ABC ngay mà uống hình Du Ngoạn thì đây
sẽ là sẽ có mặc tròn trước Đôla
a City ngoãn cách ra thì sẽ đạt tên ngôn
ngữ tên ngôn ngữ ở đây thật ra à hai
điểm hay là nó nếu mà ông ấy về giá trị
kiểu nhà nhé Tôi sẽ thử gọi
Ừ tôi sẽ thử con xô lót trước cho bé
uống xe và rất là hay là bối thằng với
là ra Swift nó tiện là kể cả cho dù nó
mà mạng ngay đúng không Thì ông truyền
vào nó là chuỗi nó sẽ tự động cách nhau
bởi dấu phẩy được mấy ông ấy
khi nào Cứ Bất kỳ khi nào mà một trong
ba hoa nhài nó được nó được hiểu dạng là
chọn nhọn thì mình sẽ kiểu mình sẽ tự
động cho Android lại
Ừ mình đây trên này
chị sẽ tạo thêm một cái dưới cùng đi
thường là tạo cái gì cung đến đây đúng
không Mình sẽ tặng cái cùng ai
ý là mỗi khi xe ngày này
Ừ tôi có thể để nghe đi
anh gửi tin nhắn Đợi tí nhé để là
ở
trên
độ on chứ
trên này rồi Thằng kia
ừ ừ
a black Company name à à
a và
c Rack City 1
anh kia những thay đổi chọn thì mình sẽ
xử lý như thế này mình sẽ gọi đến Hàm
Channels 2 cho thế là xong
rồi nhé
a cho
inspect mấy ông xe ablade của louise gà
trống lựa chọn này ra 11 này chọn này ra
như thế này nó lại đây thì nó phải ra
như thế nhưng giờ sự là bây giờ tôi có
thể gộp chung nó lại hình như này được
thì có thể y nó ra được thẳng luôn
với thằng pp rất là nó sẽ báo lỗi cái
thằng gia Speed được cái kiểu nói in
được chuỗi ra sẽ kiểu nhà
em ở bình tĩnh tí nhá Thiếu cái đóng rồi
à
khi chọn này
em à kêu đang bị một cái đó là nó lấy và
lưu chứ nó không lấy tách mình sẽ cầm
lấy tách ở đây mình sẽ cần à Để tách
kiểu gì nhỉ à
a
z tách sự thật chân
à à
anh không biết không biết tôi chưa thử
cái vụ này
khi chọn thế à
nhau bởi dấu phẩy thôi mình thể biến nó
dấu phẩy thử đầu tiên mình cứ thử con
solo chấm lót Xem thằng này bán chất nó
có phải là mảnh không đã
nó là nối với nhau thẳng luôn Nó không
phải là Mạc giờ ra tới ngày không hay
lắm Chị xem à
ờ ờ
dùng tách như thế này thì nó bị đổ
Ê pete ơ sát thật
Ừ tôi không nên dùng chấm trách ở đây
luôn đấy nó sẽ lấy toàn bộ tách hẳn luôn
à
em lấy trợ Gia Lai
còn sát Hạnh có solo trên lốp khi nghỉ
rồi tôi
Cho xem số điện thoại cho đã ngày sẽ cầm
chào với trắng mà
có nhiều phần tử mà nhiều option sex
thật mà
xe tải nó là giặc mạng Nga Sau đó mình
sẽ có
a
celestine à
thì mình sẽ có
Ừ ok biến là I need a word i i
em bận chỗ trống sau đó thì mình sẽ
duyệt hàng ngày
chấm phố ích
mẹ về nón mạng mà anh sẽ nói chuyện ở
đây tại từng hàng một
sao mình sẽ nối chuỗi
anh được
Ừ không sao đâu Tại sao giảm mất công
nhé lỗi tôi ngày nó chỉ cần đơn giản là
nối
xã hội tất cả thằng này
tôi tin tất cả các góc chân này nối với
nhau Ê bà ơi Mark II xe xe
à à Ừ
Anh đợi tin nhắn ở thế nhé
à à
gì chấm tách như này nó sẽ bị ỉa
anh nói với nhau
Ừ cái này là ma
We are map Swift
nó cứ bị chậm chậm rồi gì ngay bản chất
nó mạnh đúng không cho mình sẽ cần gọi
hàm Tech của nó lấy cái giá trị của nó
này thôi tôi có làm kiểu làm kiểu nông
dân trước anh nhá
đi sẽ cộng bằng ở đây là ích tại chấm
tách nhân 2 xong mình sẽ nối nhau bởi
dấu
phẩy này nữa
Anh ngồi đây là mạng
bộ phim sex cộng bằng như này
khi họ
tranh cách mạng ngay sau đó thì
a language bằng language
chấm choy
chỉ cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy Đây là Mạc
nối nhau dấu phẩy nó có cái đồ đấy Chúc
bạn nhanh nhá đúng giá switch
ở fort knox fashion tại sao em ạ nhỉ
có Zalo à
này đi gọi kiểu giống như vừa nãy mấy
ông kia gọi thì sẽ là
A Gọi thằng con dùng hàn Peter gọi thằng
con thì nó sẽ sẽ chẳng ra mà Hãy cập
nhật này chị Huyền khi tơ ngay cho tao
nó sẽ đi làm anh ạ
à à
có ai
a text
I speak the language
a a không để cho cún gì ạ Đã đi Kết hàng
giá trường hợp nó lừa mình lại sẽ như
này ngon
à à
em chọn một thằng ngày này
là nó vẫn lấy ra được đây thôi
ở nhà lấy được cái lạnh này thôi
vì nó không lấy ra được cái chỗ mà tôi
cần
khi tổng nó vào như này luôn
khi chọn này đội kinh
Ừ Anh nghe gọi là đi
chậm ở đâu
à à
ừ ừ
khi sex
khi mặt trời ngon chưa
ca sĩ nói
nữ ca sĩ duyệt từng phần tử này sao thì
tống nó vào
Ồ thông báo và mạng Sau đó thì mình sẽ
mình sẽ chị việc là in cái mạng à in nó
ra thôi ok
Ừ nó đi Ở đây sẽ chị thêm cái nữa là
không có đi
Ừ nếu có
ở trọ này chọn này
A và nếu có thì mình bạn chất là cái chỗ
này của mình là đây ít
đầu tiên mình sẽ có cái đoạn chỗ ấy đã
mình sẽ có lép xuynh
là bằng cả cái đoạn Trỗi đi
à mà trừ cái hàng có money này City mình
sẽ sáng phải chọn rồi nắng với chắc chắn
Minh ở chọn rồi ngày do thám hiểm ngân
hàng có xong rồi Ít company
Ừ anh yêu có thì mình sẽ cậu truyền thêm
vào trong cái chỗ này và
3 cách làm cá như thế này nó đi
từ nãy rồi đây mình sẽ chỉ đơn giản là
email cái chuỗi thôi
và Chọn ok chưa sau đó đi mình chọn ngay
là một à đậu xanh cái này phải ra là chị
sẽ là tách đúng
anh ở đây sẽ và
tôi đặt tên đẹp hay thổ đi
thay đổi Mình sẽ tạo là tự động tạo
schrock nữa
hỗ trợ giúp à
xịn đúng không
anh bị ông ba mấy ông nãy giờ xa thấy
nãy giờ tôi đi bất Có vẻ hơi sợ không
thấy nói gì cả
Anh trông ngon mà đúng không ạ
lần đấy nha nó sẽ có một cái hộp Đương
nhiên mình vẫn thể vào sửa được không ạ
này
Ừ thế này nó tiện người dùng không ạ bây
giờ phải như thế này
đó là bây giờ sự tôi sửa ngày thôi sao
tôi lại chọn lại như này thì rõ ràng nó
bị ghi đè lên cái của tôi đúng ạ Thực ra
thì ha có sợ đòn mà cái này liên quan
đến lỗi ảnh ảnh mà xóa hết anh đi được à
Anh hiểu cách nấu khỏe cũng được
anh không Chỉ cần thế này nữa được
về mặt hôi từ tính sau chín giờ bốn
trọng để ngày được sao đâu À thì
Ừ thì Nếu giả sử tôi sửa nỡ để người
dùng sữa là có người dụng hứng tay lên
chọn cái này thì có 2 cách 1 là ông vẫn
phải giữ cái đúng cái mà người dùng đã
gõ chẳng hạn thế nhiều người dùng thích
cậu bị ngược đời đó người dùng võ từ Cái
dưới đã kiểu nó thương ấy làm thay đổi
trước hả Thôi nó kéo nói cố nhìn xuống
dưới cùng để chọn thay đồ rồi Nó lại
chọn lên trên này thì tự nhiên mất cái
hồi nó gõ xem nào không ạ thì mình sẽ
làm nha đấy Thế mình sẽ bắt sự kiện để
kiểm tra lúc đầu là là nếu mà lúc đầu mà
người dùng đã lỡ gõ sai thổ rồi thì
không được phép sửa gì nữa nhớ mà nghĩa
mình sẽ cho cái kiểu cái biển trách mình
sẽ tạo một biến chế
Ê bà bằng chua iPhone gì đấy đấy em thực
tế là tôi để dưới cùng rồi Chắc là người
cũng không có trường hợp tự nhiên quay
lại chọn hết tự đóng này thông qua đây
sửa rồi mà lại quay trên sửa đâu chả
không thấy đâu tiếp theo mình sẽ có
dress Shoe Shop Nghĩa mình sturridge này
ngay khi mà trans xong cái thai khổ này
mình sẽ trance luôn và để trái nữa việc
là cái Hằng
Ê mấy thằng này nó chạy Nói chung là
phải đợi Thái Tổ xong hết rồi mà chạy
không ạ Mình sẽ truyền được biết thay
đổi trong như thế này nó chắc em nghĩ sẽ
tạo một cái thằng là lắp
Ừ thì thôi cao tạo sắc khác đơn giản
nhưng mà đương nhiên để mình tránh chung
nữa đúng không ạ thì mình sẽ cần nên gọi
gọi lên A gọi lên thằng
gọi lên api ở trên bác em để nó kiểu
kiểm tra hộ mình xem mà slot nó nó đã
hợp lệ không Mình sẽ dụng as mình sẽ
truyền cái thủ lên để mà xác nhận xe mà
lúc này có họ có được phép để mà in xơ
và không cho mình sẽ Insert đương nhiên
là mình database Hình như là tôi nhớ
mình chưa hề kiểm tra Block không được
phép chung đây là vẫn có thể trường hợp
bất đắc dĩ ở đó mà hai người cùng cùng
Nghi sốt cùng một lúc thì nó sẽ bị lỗi
nên là tôi sẽ phải sửa lại cả tao bay vụ
đấy nữa cũng trước có nhớ là tôi còn
phải sửa lại cái mới cái cột ở đây nữa
mình sẽ sửa lại cột Win bootable này cho
các thứ thuốc tê bồ này
Anh hiểu dịch hôm trước mình bảo nó là
gì nhé là kiểu cho phép Mai mốt không à
gì đó nữa
phải để nó nick nó duy nhất thì ổn hơn
thì bây giờ mình cứ tạo họ chút nhà mình
sẽ là à
ê ê
I am này enter
à à à
Âm Nhạc
Ừ anh tơ scrub
if you nick ạ
à à Enter Smart Bloom
thông tin ausable chiều ngang
ừ ừ
vì sao mình sẽ
Ê mày sẽ có cả à à
a What's right off sẽ có blog
đây này Mình vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên nó đây
Ừ hôm qua lại mình sẽ đây mình sẽ
em đổi nó thành
unique và train đ
hôm nay
em xoay đi sáng nay đi
kinh
tế là cái này đáng lẽ Hình như là tôi
nhớ là Thắm nó nó nó có hỗ trợ Ooh Hình
như là có hỗ trợ là chị thêm younes
riêng được rồi xem nhé sẻ nhạc
Anh check unique riêng
có ai đúng rồi ngủ nick gì không được
Em đỡ mất công phải cậu trên đây này
Ừ nó unique rock Nếu mà có có luôn này
được có vẻ có vẻ đúng đấy sẽ thủ này
anh alo
Anh bảo rồi
Ừ thì bây giờ để tránh trường hợp mà tự
nhiên mình tạo 2 tháng bị chung nó mình
phải báo lỗi một cái trường hợp mà đó
chị thơ tiếp theo mình quay lại với này
mình mình sẽ phải gọi Iraq mình sẽ đẩy
cái Thái Tổ lên sau đó thì nó sẽ tự động
trả về cho mình một cái as a một cái
snack nào nó khá là ổn thì mình sẽ làm
hay sao tớ xin phép copy đoạn bên giác
này cho nhanh
một vì ở cái này sẽ không phải mỗi bên
admin dùng có thể bên A bên bên người
đăng tuyển dụng có thể rung nên là mình
sẽ gọi điện api nó luôn mình sẽ là gọi
đến router cái bi ai
ạ sau đó đi chấm post thằng ạ và
lắc trắng ạ Nhưng ai
Ừ cái này là vẫn chất là mình sẽ đẩy lên
đẩy lên hơi cái ít thông tin và mình sẽ
phản hồi lại đúng mỗi cái lắc thôi em
mình thấy để dạng nén được không Mình
gặp em nhưng chả phê thì mình nên chả
dạng Leesin luôn Thế tiếp theo là para
mình chửi lên là thái Hồ sẵn rồi truyền
hình hay tổ
thế này
xe máy
Không
biết giờ này được không trả được
ở Đông Ngạc
tí đủ sẽ biết
đàn fail fail này nhưng không chọn nó
lắm
ý nghĩa vụ đan phê nó là như thế nào nhé
Ừ nó là sắp xít về alo
sẽ trả về cái gọi xong này nhìn báo lỗi
thì sao
bộ phim sex mình sẽ báo lỗi khi mà không
cherub được cái gì đó chẳng hạn thế
Ừ tao cũng không chuyện đấy
hình ảnh mình sẽ thử con solo chấm lót ở
đây xem
qua trở về nhé
sẽ là cái chị ai
chị sẽ tạo đây một cái đường Linh
bóng đá
anh lắng nghe nhạc
ở đây sẽ chăm sóc sáng ạ và đây sẽ là
janus
I stop nó
cho mình bản chất ở đây mình sẽ có
phần chân translate
thì mình sẽ
tôi thường hay làm ở như này thì tao
chịu mày luôn bây giờ ngay trai các cậu
ngay nghĩa là nếu mà có vấn đề gì đó Khi
mà tạo cái lắc của có vấn đề thì tôi sẽ
Return một cái là Euro Nếu không nhiều
không ạ Nếu không nhớ vụ Euro và xấu xí
trong chất mình làm không ạ và mặc định
là mình sẽ ghi tên sắp xít ngay cho đã
cái thì ở đây mình bạn chắc là mình sẽ
truyền đây lắp không ạ Mấy ông thích vai
đứt đoạn này tùy Tôi thấy được là nó
không không quá nhiều gai biết mình sẽ
chỉ đơn giản là lấy sóc ở trên như này
thôi bằng doris lessing IV
Ừ nếu mà ít MT Nếu mà sóc gà trống
chắc hơn thì à
ta0 Thế làm sư trong vai đi nhỉ
khi được Nếu muốn tôi sẽ làm vài đất ở
nay luôn đây mình sẽ có là thế lắc nó
ngoại mình sẽ tạo ra đi cho làm từ đầu
đến cuối nó chuẩn thì vì cái này liên
quan không phải bên admin mà liên quan
đến cả bên bên khác thì mình sẽ có ai
quy này make request này mình sẽ có là
tôi thường là tên nó sẽ post cái chéo
như thế này sau đó thì tên của cái hàm
này thế mà Friends blog sẽ stress này
nhà Chữ với cái hoa này rồi thì chị web
nha Cái
đi đám cưới quét này
à à
mình sẽ phải có Âu thì chắc chắn là phải
mình nhưng mà đang Chưa anh chưa làm
được Sang Woo đấy có mặc định cho nó
đúng mình sẽ có lắp
à mà nó sẽ có là tiên là bắt buộc phải
sinh rồi buộc phải quay rồi
và bắt buộc chị sẽ One Piece như thế này
tức à Không được để chấm Đúng ở đây xanh
đàn ông
anh lại không phải để sống
ở
ngoài bắt buộc phải điền này ba bộ là
chỗ này một cái cho cháu
Em hãy cái Đỗ này ok à
ok rồi
ờ ờ
nó lắc mày
luôn à kiểm tra luôn đây Note S ở trong
cái post này nữa cũng được
Ờ Ờ
nó taxes ở trong boss
anh Bởi vì bây giờ mình đang tạo mà đang
tạm thì cần nhiều sẽ không trung em cho
anh
đang tạo thế mới còn nếu mà giả sử tí
mình sửa thì mình có thể gọi đến đường
link này Nhưng mà mình sẽ phải thêm một
cái gì đó Nói chung nhà mình mình phải
kiểm tra mi hót cũng được một cách
thì
mình sẽ ở đây có ru này
ở đà notice
ở nick à
ở nick gì nhỉ Anh chửi thề bồ này
Anh
tốt này à
Tuấn nhà được bộ đồ nha Được
class nó được
a tiếp theo là có lum
ạ sau đó đi mình sẽ có mình sẽ có ra
được rồi
anh không Anh em kém xe sai bảo em dễ
đâu Lúc này
đợi tí
có thằng nào nó có cái hàm để mà tao lúc
thì bạn nhớ hết pin nó có
à à
em đang như thế này
Ừ nhưng mà như bạn chất là mình vẫn sẽ
phải kiểm tra
thì mình sẽ tạo cái Smart của nó gì
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
tạo ra một cái thằng ship mới nghỉ
Apple này
anh Khánh chồng nữa còn chọn Sáng chung
à
ở đây đây
The Flash
á nhon giờ mình sẽ tắm cái hả mày nữa
được
khi sex
cơ mà thư viện này là thư viện này nó
Ừ thì vẫn thư viện này cũng có bé tạo
slack mà như vừa rồi
có truyền ở nó cũng chuyển vào
được cái này thay thôi nhé á
Ừ để thay thồ
trên thay thổ lên sau đó thì mình sẽ tạo
tạo spa dựa trên Thái Tổ
Vì sao gì ở sai sai đây à
ạ Bây giờ mình mới phải vào slack mà
đúng không ạ
bộ lọc xơ viết này
à report blog phẩm string là cái tô nó
lúc thôi
cho thuê nhà viết đúng không
có
ai sẽ luôn trả về ở dưới xuân này về rồi
này ờ
lên này lấy gốc lên cho mình xem Giả sử
Tôi Chọn Một cái như này
khi họ sẽ truyền lên
Ở trên anh sai rồi đúng không
Ơ sao lại chuyển Đây là thay khô
này à
trả về
One Piece Note II giá
đúng rồi nhỉ Cái xanh thả đợi xem nhé
đây và Yết
à à
em yêu
ngày phiêu rồi lỗi tội lỗi tôi
à à
thì nó sẽ trả về data và nhà luôn chị
nào nó mình sẽ chỉ phải in người ta ra
thôi
xe xe
em sửa lại cái này
Ừ mình Death flag
anh ở đây sẽ ra Bphone ta
trang này
à à
sang đến update Delete phải thật
á nhon
này à
Ừ nó bị dài tự nhiên là người dùng nó để
sửa được
ở những Tôi bảo là người dùng thể sửa
được toàn bộ Cái này thì người dùng thì
sửa được nóng ạ sau đó thì mình vẫn sẽ
phải kiểm tra phát nữa mình sẽ lợn vẫn
vẫn phải kiểm tra phát nữa xem là Smart
này có hợp lệ hay không thì mình sẽ cũng
có thêm một IP ai nữa thì kiểm tra mỗi
việc và snack hợp lệ thì mình thông báo
mình sẽ nghĩa người dùng Điền soạn Điền
đến bước ai rồi ông ạ Nói chung cứ mỗi
lần người dùng đi ăn xong mình sẽ luôn
kiểm tra để cắn nuốt mình có thể được
phép Cậu sắp ít hay không em ông đi du
học là sự tôi cũng sẽ biết ở đây nhá Tôi
sẽ có cái cuối này tôi sẽ có một cái đít
đây là home group đúng không là for
groups
Từ ngày mình Spartan để mà xe buýt gần
trước
chợ
tết này và mình có class ở đây là
I gotta này tin Sắp xếp này
đúng không Và mình sẽ có ID là vô tâm
cho mít ngon
thông tin xe buýt nay
nhờ mỗi lần cả thằng này nó được được
thay đổi thì giá trị như thế mình sẽ
phải check mình phải gọi đến Hàm
check-lock kiểu cờ thế để mà kiểm tra
xem là nó kiểu có phù hợp hay không
gọi đến
thì
mình sẽ phải
em mặc áo rách gọi lên
thứ ngày
Ừ
cái này
nghĩ phải đặt tên lại một cái class Mark
một cái là
cái này post đi post 1 ghét đi
a hot thìa để mà
I
bought The tragic và ghét ở để check
ở nhà đi một cái là cách
a mess
lông mày
có nét đây cái trách một cái á
Ừ ok
Anh nhìn thấy á là suisse tao đang sợ
nhỉ hồi tôi làm sự hủy đoạn này sợ quá
Chưa ạ
là mấy thấp
Lý Hải mới thật ở dưới này sẽ mới thấy
ghét mình sẽ truyền lên mình chuyển lên
sẽ là
lắp là bản chất là mình sẽ đldt
cái thằng mà lại Mình ra cho đến ba lô
lấy giá trị của nó
Anh thích kiểm tra nếu mà nếu thành công
thì đương nhiên là mình cái nút Tần
a Smith
rất hay mình sẽ cho đi xây bồ
Ê bà Phone này đấy
extrapone chấm Sắp ship
ông ngoại
có tiền thì tôi có tạm cho cả hai bằng
chu trước đã
nó lúc mà thay đổi mình luôn kiểm tra
những thành công thì mình sẽ cho bằng
Phone ngay là hợp lý còn đâu tất cả
những cái chung ở còn lại thì mình sẽ kệ
mình sẽ hiểu được là nó không thỏa mãn
lại như này công nghệ thuật cho mình xem
nhé
ờ ờ
tại lại sang này
à à
có thể mặc định lúc đầu cho đi xây bồ
mặc định là chua được
a thistle nhé
em mặc định là không không cho bọn đấy
số đó thì khi mà chọn các tối thứ ngay
Em hãy translate Ừ Vậy thì đợi thì à
ở Hà Nội Cái cái này mình đã làm gì đâu
Nó đang chưa gọi được đến đây mình sẽ
tạo một cái hàm là hàm để nó chết Lát nó
hợp lệ không à
Ừ đợi tí tao bớt bớt
em đặt tên là Hà Jack Plus này
ông bà Ông thích ông ấy hệ tạo một cái
đi ngang ở đây nếu mà bản chất là cà phê
đết kia Thực ra nó rất là tiện rồi
cho cây cà ri quét này kiểm tra hộ mấy
ông rất tiện rồi đấy
thì ông chị em rảnh Return sắp xít ở đây
Thôi được rồi
những câu chuyện nha
khi cài đặt check đầy đúng không
Nói chất xử hết cho ông ngay từ bên à
ở biển request rồi
chị đã kiểm tra xem mà có phù hợp để mà
anh em hả cậu làm tiếp 20 rồi
à à
khi bị nhạc chuông
Anh đừng có trêu em
số điện thoại Tắt thấy nó giữ giờ Đã lâu
lắm rồi không thấy thấy thầy Tuấn và dự
lắc nãy anh sẽ ở đây à vẫn mặc định sẽ
là
ngoạn đi quay bắt buộc phải khó này cho
chuyện này và bắt buộc phải uống nước
không ạ
Ê bà ru sẽ là trước cái vươn Alo Nicky
à à
nữa thì bên này bên này bạn chắc là sim
Mà Cọ đến hàng check lắc thấy rồi kìa
ông chỉ cần quý cuộn Return được mỗi vì
con sắp xít thôi à sau anh Canada gì cả
Ừ vậy sao tùy rõ à ba đến nó làm sợ hết
bạn kia rồi
Ừ thế là ta ở đây mặc định nó thể là
chồng nốt nhà đi không bắt buộc phải
điện cái tác dụng của về param là ông
muốn mặc điện mặc định làm cái gì đó để
không lỡ bắt buộc phải điền nó sẽ như
thế này
Ừ ok
Tại sao con nữa này chẳng cần tải đâu ạ
ở chỗ này
a slack này nó trả về
Ừ
Đợi thì đợi thì
trên mà nhỉ
sự thay đổi giá trị mà
anh nhiều chưa chích cơ cái trên
em chưa mình vào đây rồi nhưng mình chưa
chích ở trên này thì cho Bống xem nhé
Tôi thử con solo chấm lóc ở đây xem biết
được ngay là nó có chí câu với thằn
chuyện em nhé á
kiện
cái đôi trên Bây giờ mình sẽ chết cơ
trên valeu
gj
well even
hãy nếu không muốn phải lòng đầy đủ ở
như thế
thì mình sẽ à
ở trên functional không phải à à
khi chấm dứt girl từ xa
công đến cái thằng Trí cây để mình kích
hoạt chí kêu cho nó như này
cha mẹ chết là xong à
gọi thủ công như thế là được rồi à
anh gọi lại Đấy được rồi nút hiển thị ra
món ăn không ngon lắm đấy Như trong
trường hợp mà cái check của mấy ông nó
là hợp lệ nó sẽ sắp xít như này mình có
thật sự là toilet ơn một cái phê rồi em
ạ thì cái nút nó sẽ không được không ạ
Nó sẽ không được
sát của tôi thì có suốt các thứ ở đây
không xem thôi
Ừ
ông vẫn chưa biết nữa đi khắp của tôi
đúng không
Chai hiệu tên tôi ra đấy vì là lời sẽ có
cái Zippo này mà nãy giờ xử tôi ra tôi
toàn quen tại tra được không cần tại
trang đâu đấy thì ông sẽ thấy nó bị báo
như này nó j-phone ở đây và 400 luôn như
thế này thì gần như là cái nút này nó sẽ
không được clip không ạ Cái sau A
đây bây giờ mày Ông thấy à Cũng tương
đối
Cái gì đó thôi không có thời gian để làm
thêm cái gì nữa tôi sẽ nhập hết đoạn này
sao mình sẽ crack
á nhon bị quét thêm
anh mãi gửi buổi đến đoạn kết tài trợ
Ừ xong mình sẽ của Arsenal sẽ nhảy đến
thấy làm việc nhưng mà tôi đang làm rất
là cẩn thận mày không thấy cái lỗ tỉ mỉ
cẩn thận kiểu tay bế các thứ rất cẩn
thận Dạo này không ạ
Ừ dạo này sẽ ở bên An ninh mình sẽ có
clip ở đây mình có quyết thôi chị sẽ ra
amine.net impressed i
anh nghe này con gì em nghỉ ở trong nhà
thôi mấy thớt là tốt khi mình tự nhiên
có cái xếp rồi đấy những này ngoan
á nhon cho mình sẽ Cậu sắp với phomai
thử xem thế nào
ở đây bên A web này
tên hàm phải Store
How to nhé nhầm đấy ạ
à à
thế này
Ừ nó
anh xóa tôi sẽ
cách lắp ních phóng sinh đ
How to ngay đấy thì giống như vừa nãy
tôi bảo là cái này mình nên nên trả về
thông báo thành công ấy thất bại mình sẽ
trai cát ở đây này
Ừ cái này như này là mặc định mình sẽ
mình sẽ luôn reuter là sắp xít ngoạn vào
ngược lại thì sẽ Return Euro ngày
for chết
mặc định và trả về Vision đó mình luôn
nên trả lời cái cái cái gì đó như thế
tiếp theo thằng ngày bản chất là mình sẽ
ơi mình đương nhiên là mình bên admin
lại thì mình có thể không làm chặt với
cái vụ à
bodage Tôi đã bảo rồi không cần được làm
chẳng phụ ra tết thì mình là hạn chị lấy
thông tin về tôi thử CD hoặc Return thử
cho ông doris ngọn đến ô Lấy toàn bộ giá
trị mình đã nhập về xem xem trong nhà
nhé
ừ ừ
này béo có Real lại cái này cho bị có
tay tràn bộ đệm không được gì đó
em chọn lại
khi họ
anh gọi liên tục gọi liên tục tại mình
phải cách của đoạn này khó cách khó mình
ở luôn kiểm tra lại nhưng nó cho một
đoạn này Đấy do May mà nó là unique nên
là nó được đánh nách rồi
cho nên nó bắt nhanh
tục liên tục nóng lạnh ở
à mà sửa không cần điền máy kia ẩn crit
thì mình sẽ bản chất là mình sẽ lưu lại
tất cả đúng ai rồi ạ thì mình sẽ
Mình lưu lại ở trong bài đăng này
Company này sao language này nhưng nhưng
Ê mấy ông hãy để ý là hôm trước tôi đã
bảo là nếu mà giờ xử người dùng nhập một
cái công ty mới một kịch Company mới
hoàn toàn ngoại
Anh vừa rồi là người dùng người dùng à
chọn cái có sẵn thì nó sẽ ra là một như
này đúng không ạ Nó sẽ ra số rồi ngay
nhưng nếu mà giờ sự người dùng nhập nhập
vào không ạ thì mình sẽ phải làm như thế
nào ở đây bài toán là mình sẽ
mình sẽ phải lấy được cái người dùng đã
nhập cơ à
Ừ nhưng mà đoạn lấy hơi khó kiểm tra thì
mình sẽ phải kiểm tra xem ạ Cái này nó
lại đi Hãy nó là Ừ nó là dạng số 2 tặng
chửi
Em không hiểu ý tôi không ạ
bố mẹ tôi đoạn này tôi nghĩa là công
quân y này thôi nghĩa lấy - cái giá trị
chữ thì hợp lý hơn là vui cả làng cuối
cùng thể Nha Trang web dow người dùng
không sử là bây giờ không cho người dùng
nhập đi mình cũng cứ mặc định có hết sẵn
người dùng có rồi thể nhập được like mới
không nhỉ
chắc chắn nó trong mình dùng nhập người
dùng nhập như thế này
cho class này thì nó sẽ là ra cái mới
này không nghĩa Company ở trong xưởng
này tôi muốn luôn đấy là chữ Chứ nhìn
chị Lan như này để xong rồi mình kiểm
tra việc trùng và mình đi xuất chứ Nếu
mà bây giờ cũng chọn như thế này thì ông
không biết được lúc nó số lúc thì nó chữ
thi công thức khó kiểm tra ông có thể là
ép nó thành số ra Ông kiểm tra theo ID
cũng được Nhưng nếu Giả sử ngựa đâu
người dùng nhập số ngày thật và tên đấy
tên Company của họ thật là sự ngay đi
cái này ra lại sai đúng không ạ trong
triều ngoài Tôi nghĩ đó à Xong rồi dùng
à à mình mình sẽ phải lấy lấy hẳn giá
trị value là chuỗi chữ đây tôi sẽ thử
thôi sẽ thử mình sẽ có
xe Mercedes hay đúng không ạ
ờ ờ sẽ lấy Zalo của nó
Ừ ok Simulator
à à
khi sex
anh không hiểu này lắm
mình đang xử lý đặt Blue của này đây
mình sẽ nó lên luôn đi Đấy mình sẽ có ba
lô nó chính là lên ngay
không có trọng nữa
Việt Nam
Ừ nó ốc đất xanh
I say
à à đó sửa nhầm cho sữa ngắm lỗi tội lỗi
rồi
anh sữa ở bên A
à Không có gì đây này
à à
kiểm tra mình sẽ kiểm tra Company này
tồn tại hay chưa chưa mình sẽ thêm mới
và thêm mới nhỉ Nếu mà chưa ấy thì mình
sẽ
số 1 là thêm mới
à hay là sẽ hiện sẽ nhảy sang cái phom
để cho người dùng thêm company
ý nghĩa là mình thêm mới tự động có một
cách mà cái hiển thị form để người dùng
mà thêm cũng được
Ừ mà tự động Điền City lại đi Chết cho
người ta luôn cũng được để cho người
dùng trên sắc sắp xác nhận thôi Nếu có
người dọn ấy Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ làm cách
hay những bộ Hôm nay chị nhờ cũng hơi
dài rồi và thấy hôm nay mấy ông có vẻ
hơi bị thoáng nhỉ thấy hơi choáng nhưng
mà trình Trịnh Trịnh các thử này không
Tôi nghĩa không khó bằng bữa trước cũng
trước làm Vision nó còn khó hơn những bộ
hôm nay cũng à
em cũng nhiều phép ngoài tôi nghĩ là
cũng tương đối kiến thức đấy chứ nhỉ
kiểm tra có nhiều thứ làm thử hưởng bữa
mày tạm tạm thời Thế đã có gì buổi sau
Tiếp nha Rồi sao chắc cụ xong nốt cái
đoạn thêm này có lẽ hơi tốn hơn nhiều
thời gian tôi làm hơi bị
xem tivi quá đoạn với cái đoạn này nhưng
về sau Tìm mình này mình thấy copy hoa
quả mình hình dung được cái bài toán
thôi mình lại sang cái thằng khác thì nó
làm nó nhanh hơn đâu vậy độ không giảm
kỹ đoạn này nữa không ạ
em hỏi ông là sửa Tôi cao diện loài vật
em chụp ảnh
dùng nháy cái muốn chat được gì đấy
ca nhạc buổi mày sao tặng ngừng đây á
không em yêu treo máy rồi
Chào mấy ông nhé